Any more questions have you ever met a flash like
everybody else has ever met him i thought it was
an unbearable d-bag have you met wonder woman i've
never met her but she did spend an entire party if
me from across the room sick dude dude i said
effin welcome back everyone this is going to be
my full dc peacemaker episode 6 video there were
a bunch of easter eggs we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes and we have a
whole bunch of batman movie stuff that's going to
be happening really soon so i'll be doing videos
for everything careful for spoilers if you have
not seen the episode yet we'll just start at the
beginning and work our way through scene by scene
talking about easter eggs and wtf moments as we
go along starting with the episode title murn
after reading a reference to the phrase burned
after reading in the team finding out mirn is a
butterfly what's going on with the butterflies
just in general and as a reference to peacemaker's
fake diary as in burn this after reading but
the actual opening scene is the rest of the
cliffhanger with mirn coming after leota in the
reveal that harcourt herself just learned recently
after their mission to take down goff when he
survived a huge blast to the face and mirn came
clean to her and john economos actually knows they
kind of played for a little bit of comedy like
oh he sticks his fingers in his ears he doesn't
want to know about it but amanda waller does not
know so this is big secret that they're keeping
from her now is all part of leota slowly turning
against amanda waller because she's still very
much following her mother's orders she planted the
diary but she's having misgivings now and you have
all the stuff that harcourt has been feeding her
about amanda waller being the most evil person on
the planet the whole idea with suicide squad based
stories is that amanda waller often winds up being
one of the bigger villains this sort of dovetails
with what's going on with the peacemaker storyline
like how they going to save him from getting the
death sentence because now they have the diary
framing him for all these murders it's all about
leota eventually turning against amanda waller and
coming clean to the team about what she did also
letting the team know that she is amanda waller's
daughter if it wasn't clear the rest of the team
does not know about the connection between her
and amanda waller yet then we find out that the
golf butterfly that peacemaker just got high with
he's been getting high with is actually their
queen they originally came to earth as refugees
because their planet was dying meant to be a
big superman krypton reference superman coming
to earth because kryptom was about to be destroyed
except when they came to earth instead of peaceful
coexistence eventually their queen and her
supporters within their culture pretty much
their entire race decided to just conquer earth
instead it'd be much easier for them in the mern
butterfly was the sole dissenter so it's basically
him against his entire race and amanda waller does
not know that mirn is a butterfly they've given
us a little bit of mern's backstory the actual
mirn character before he became a butterfly
they also confirmed that when butterflies take
over people they effectively kill them like that's
why all that blood was coming out of all the cops
mouths as the butterflies were taking over their
bodies so like detective song for instance if the
butterfly queen left her body she would just fall
into a lump of flesh on the ground but they imply
that as bad as it was that the mern butterfly
took over mirn's body like he understands it
was bad what he did killing mirn but the original
murn was a terrible person killed a whole bunch
of people like he had that conversation with
locke where they talk about their backstory
i explained it was a big superman comic book
easter egg they committed all this genocide in
north africa and it was at some point after that
that the butterfly took over mirn so as bad as it
is that the butterflies are killing people this
version of mern the butterfly mirn is actually
a better person just in general than the original
mirn was it's a very morally gray situation which
is a classic trope of suicide squad stories like
none of the main characters are meant to be truly
evil or truly good like a bunch of a-holes but
they ultimately wind up saving the world from a
way worse situation but there are a couple people
on the show that they want you to think of as
truly evil like really bad irredeemable people
white dragon probably being chief among them
but then they had the funny scene a peacemaker
visiting jameel's daughter's class telling them
the story of how he captured kite man whose news
article we saw decorating his home kite man one
of the most ridiculous batman villains you've
probably seen him in all the dc harley quinn
animated series episodes the only batman villain
i would say that's more ridiculous that gets
referenced a lot is condiment king he is probably
the most ridiculous villain that you'll see in
a lot of the tv shows they make a whole bunch of
justice league references and you have to remember
that because this is taking place in the dc eu the
justice league characters they're talking about
are like ezra miller's flash galactose wonder
woman ben affleck's batman henry cavill superman
one of the little kids points out a bunch of flaws
in his kite man takedown and it's very typical of
little kids like if you've ever talked to a group
of little kids for an extended period of time
things like this happen all the time regardless
of what kind of story you're telling them they'll
start poking holes in it like little kids being
way more clever than you would expect them to be
the black heart ruby that kite man stole in
peacemaker's story isn't something from dc comics
they just invented it for the episode but it's
not some secret magical artifact it's just meant
to be a very rare valuable gemstone that kite
man tried to steal but owning himself like that
trying to steal ruby that was too heavy for him to
carry is totally something that kite man would do
like trying to pull off a heist and failing
hilariously without batman ever having to
try and lift a finger to catch him so it's a
joke about how stupid and lame kite man is and
at the same time peacemaker also kind of owning
himself because he goes way overboard trying to
catch him which is also a classic peacemaker he
owns himself a lot during his conversation with
the little kids here really good example of that
is when the little kid brings back the joke about
the coterie of super villains that he was arguing
about with the old neighbor who was calling him
out for not being as cool as batman if you don't
know who alfred newman is when he's trying to make
fun of the little girl here on the flash t-shirt
the joke is that he's actually the cover boy
on mad magazine the character depicted in that
cartoonish way and the little girl is a ginger
like him it's more about peacemaker being a bully
which they called him out for a couple episodes
ago because he calls the other kid chubster he
low-key pretty much makes fun of every single
kid in the classroom then later they call him
out and is basically peacemaker acting like more
of a child than the actual children here but she
asks him about the flash and he tries to say that
everyone thinks that the flash is an unbearable
douchebag remember this is ezra miller's flash
he says wonder woman was giving him bedroom eyes
at a party he makes a steve urkel reference and
i love the canadian tuxedo shout out if you don't
know what that is it's basically a jean jacket and
jean pants worn together he does have a bit of
a ptsd flashback and they give us more of what
happened with his brother and how he died it seems
like from the situation they're presenting us with
that his father made them fight and maybe he
just accidentally killed him during their fight
we'll probably get the rest of the story about
what really happened in the next two episodes
my favorite one too is the little girl who thinks
that peacemaker is her father because he got it on
with her mom the bartender at the local bar that
he always goes to on the show about 10 years ago
meaning that it's totally possible for him to be
her father maybe maybe they'll have like a payoff
joke at the end of the series like some sort of
tag scene where they just reference that again the
little kid is also calling him out for not being
very original with his pet names like eagerly you
call your pet eagle eagerly is also meant to set
up the whole joke with him admitting to keeping
dangerous pets like the butterfly and eagerly
as a way to overcompensate for his insecurity
i think him going on about people that keep big
tigers as pets is also meant to be a tiger king
joke but joe exotic then the butterfly queen tries
to communicate with him trying to call a truce
making the peace sign in the jar they make a whole
bunch of movie references pitch black aliens e.t
close encounters all sci-fi movies involving alien
encounters vigilante also low-key implies that he
wants to become a woman so they can get pregnant
also his ringtone is barbie girl by aqua so maybe
there's something going on there he's kind of
on the same redemption arc the peacemaker is on
like he's slowly becoming more self-aware just
at a slower rate than peacemaker just played in
a more buffoonish kind of way one of his saving
graces though is that vigilante will have these
savant-like moments where he'll say something
that actually winds up being really useful later
on which i think will also be very useful when
they're fighting white dragon i'll talk about
that in a second too there was something he said
a couple episodes ago about white dragon's armor
that i think will be very useful when they're
trying to fight him so as dumb as both of them
are there are brief moments of brilliance from
both of them as we all guessed the police find
peacemaker's fake diary planted on amanda waller's
orders it's full of all kinds of alt-right extreme
rhetoric details about all the crimes that have
been happening in the city in evergreen that
have to do with the butterflies basically framing
peacemaker for everything that's happened recently
and i think this just confirms that amanda waller
had the fake diary created as a fail-safe measure
in case things went sideways with the mission it
was like a contingency plan to keep the police
or the authorities from connecting anything
back to her or the american government and
get rid of peacemaker at the same time basically
amanda waller throwing peacemaker under the bus
confirming everything that harcourt has been
saying to leota about her being the worst person
on the planet the butterfly queen winds up taking
over detective song's body effectively killing her
they do get a really cool assist from eagerly
when they're escaping who is hardcore i love
all the eagerly takedowns and from locke who
actually comes off as being even crazier than both
peacemaker and vigilante while they're freaking
out escaping peacemaker keeps yelling about not
understanding cloud backups because he was in
prison for so long but he does know about kpop
and it sounds like he's a blackpink fan the reason
there's so many music references on the show and
kind of baked into the character especially with
all the hair metal is because james gunn is such
a huge fan of that music we learned vigilante's
phone password is peacemaker's birthday because
he's obsessed with peacemaker and vigilante is
also a taylor swift stand note to self clear that
browsing history before you loan your phone
to another person love the joke about locke
trying to pin the murders of all the cops on the
hamburglar like was this peace picker no it was
someone with a striped shirt a red tie in a fedora
he said rubble rubble and ran off later they also
make a pennywise it reference when talking about
lock and he does come off very creepy just like it
when the queen calls the rest of her people and
then tells fitzgibbons just enjoy the moment it'll
be better for everyone it's just foreshadowing
them coming and taking over all their bodies
like you're gonna die the minute we take over your
body so just enjoy the moment that you have here
the coverdale ranch where the butterflies are
making the amber fluid or getting the fluid from
that special cow seems like it might be another
hair metal reference to dave coverdale the lead
singer of white snake and deep purple just because
there's so many hair metal references in the show
and if it wasn't clear what's going on with the
special cow they imply that a butterfly has just
implanted itself in the cow and has somehow
modified the cow's body so that it will produce
the special amber fluid i think that's meant to
pay off the reference after last week's episode
when they said that the butterflies could also
put themselves in animals after the police let
white dragon out of prison he puts together a
group of clan members then suits up in his super
villain white dragon costume from the comics but
like i said remember how vigilante was pointing
out its weaknesses a couple episodes ago the cloth
portions between the armor plates where you could
stab him or shoot him like the armor is hardcore
it's meant to be hypertech way beyond anything
the peacemaker and the team can fight they want to
make him seem like he's almost unkillable in that
armor but the armor has critical flaws that they
can exploit then peacemaker admits what vigilante
was implying earlier that he doesn't want to kill
people anymore it's all part of his character arc
just becoming more self-aware becoming less of a
douche culminating i think and finally confronting
his father luke skywalker darth vader style
but with the way they're treating his character
just being so hilariously racist and over-the-top
cartoon villain i just do not see any way that he
comes out of this show being redeemed in any way
we find out peacemaker's secret skill is playing
the piano the song that he plays is home sweet
home by motley crew and it's just meant to be
a metaphor for how he wants to go back to the way
things were when his brother was still alive when
they were together and he was happy like the
classic idea of home sweet home that he can't
go back to because his brother's dead and his
father white dragon is now trying to kill him as
the saying goes you can't go home again the queen
uses her army of butterflies to take control of
the entire police force as she foreshadowed in the
prisoners in the jail too calling open season on
peacemaker using locke's memories to get the diary
and reveal it to the world like i said earlier in
the video i think the only way they'll be able to
save peacemaker from getting the death sentence
like fully taking the brunt of all this stuff is
if leota confesses to the team what she did for
amanda waller the diary is a fake and then rebels
against her mother also revealing to the team that
she is her daughter they kind of imply that she's
ready to do that almost but they'll probably have
some tender moment between her and peacemaker
where she admits everything and then agrees to
help him it's sort of a parallel for the end of
the suicide squad movie when the whole team rebels
against amanda waller and tries to stay in quartal
maltese to defeat starro and save the locals
the post-credit scene for the episode is just a
funnier longer version of locke trying to psych
himself up to lie to fitzgibbon and detective song
about the cops being killed the way they play it
it seems kind of like a blooper reel or outtakes
but this actually might be him in the context of
the episode for real trying to psych himself up
just because he's such a weird character this
feels like something that he would actually do but
they're still heading to the butterflies ranch to
kill their special cow in next week's episode they
still have to deal with judomaster who's alive and
white dragon and his clan members are now coming
for them they actually might be able to pin a lot
of the damage in the last two episodes on white
dragon that might be part of their solution for
wrapping up all the loose ends everyone post all
your finale theories in the comments below and if
you did spot any other easter eggs in the episode
that i didn't mention in the video just write them
below in the comments my full peacemaker episode
7 video will post next thursday just like normal
there are two episodes left big reminder i just
finished posting my star wars book of boba fett
episode 6 video probably the best episode of
the series so far you can click here for that
and click here for that brand new marvel
doctor strange 2 iron man announcement
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!